[Music]
Christian
[Applause]
[Music]
Christian
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening welcome to the table my
name is James Turner
hold it up
to we better there we
go all right we'll start that again I
want to thank you all for being here
this evening um my name is James
pronouns he and him and uh I want to
thank you for being here whether you're
in person or online know that you are
family and you are loved you were
accepted as you are whether you have
been with us from the foundation of this
church or whether today is your first
time coming here know that you are loved
and accepted
welcome we have a few announcements
before we begin our
service first we have the uh state-of
the table meeting that's happening
tonight everyone is welcome to come here
updates on everything from Ministry
teams to finances we want to operate
with as much transparency and open
Communications as possible so if you
have a vested interest in this community
please stick around after the service
for this important meeting then uh we
have the welcome to the class table
Sunday March 3rd if you're new here and
curious about who we are and our story
or if you'd like to become a member of
the table this classes for you Sunday
March 3rd from 300 p.m. to 4:30 p.m.
here at first saxi child care will be
provided uh sign up using the QR code or
F out a card at the table over here to
your right and drop it in the
box now I'd like for us to go ahead and
prepare our hearts and Minds for worship
if you want to you can close your
eyes relax your
body focus on your breathing the beat of
your heart
feel the floor beneath you be
present let's set aside the hustle and
bustle of the week our trials and
failures and be here now let us open our
hearts and Minds to the peaceful
movement of God In This Place among the
people God has gathered
together let us
pray blessed are you Lord God of all
creation it is through your goodness
that we find peace and fullness of being
but often Lord we fall short we try
ruling Our Lives by our own light
putting you on the periphery of our
existence neglecting to follow the path
that you light for us we become lost we
stumble we sin we end up bruised
battered and broken by our own
shortcoming
Lord we know your nature is love and we
turn to you for
compassion understanding and healing be
with us Lord Heal us give us sight as we
seek to follow your path we ask this
Lord in the name of Jesus Christ your
son who lives and reigns with you in the
unity of the Holy Spirit one God forever
and ever
amen thank you so much for starting us
off tonight if you guys want to stand
and join us we're going to um do good
God again we learned this a couple
Sundays ago so let's sing it out if you
know it or uh learn it with
[Music]
us all right sing be still my soul
Be Still My
Soul Be Still My
Soul be still and know that my God is
here be still my
soul Be Still My
Soul be still and know that my God is
here all that I need to know is there
you are a good God maker of heaven calls
me head you are a good God and your
heart in my chain you are a good God all
that I have to do is you are a good
[Music]
god sing I
won't I won't be prais
I won't be
afraid I won't be afraid my God is here
he will make he will make a
way he will make a
way you will make a way my God is here
oh that I know is there you are a good
god of heav
you are a good
god
heart you are a good God all that I
have you you are a good
[Music]
God we're going to sing you gave me your
eyes you gave me your
heart you gave gave me your eyes you
gave me your heart your spirit flows
through my veins you gave me your eyes
you gave me your heart your spirit flows
through my oh you gave me your eyes you
gave me your heart your spirit flows
through my vein and you gave me your
right you gave me your heart you had a
right from the start and I know who I am
I know who you are you are a good God
all that I need to know is
this the maker of heaven calls
me and all that I need to know is there
you are a good god maker of heaven
you are a good God and your heart in my
you are a good God all that I have to do
is you are a good
goding know this you are a good
god
care you are a good God your heart is in
my CH you are a good God all that I have
to
do you are a good god yes you are a good
God you are a good God you are a good
God you are a good God you are a
good God
all right our teachers are going to make
their way over here and our kids are
going to line up behind them and then
they will take them to their rooms thank
you kids ministry so much for all that
you do I know Chrissy pierman and Katie
salsman and the daughters are serving
tonight and Nancy pretty thank you guys
so
much y'all are awesome
[Music]
all right we are going to move into the
prayers of the people um most of you
know how we do this but if you guys
would read this prayer aloud with me and
then um we're going to leave space and
you can speak out a name or situation
that's on your heart um and we just
believe together that God is here with
us that he wants to hold those with us
um and we want to hold them with each
other and then we'll close out the
prayer again together would you guys
pray aloud Jesus for this city of saxi
Texas and for every city and community
and all who live in them we pray to you
for the Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the Widow and and orphan for the
injured and suffering we pray to you for
the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us so we lift these names and situations
up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen I lose my
ability to be afraid when I see the Way
You Love
me all fear my Fe to the
floor it don't hold me
anymore when I see your
face Everything Changes in the radiance
of your smile
he got this way
of chasing away
those Shadows that hang
around so Lord I fall
down
again I'm fighting out just who I
am lose my ability
to be afraid when I hear you say my
name and all the voices that want filled
my
head they are gone when you
speak see your
face Everything Changes
the radiance of your
[Applause]
[Music]
smile you got this way
up chasing away
those Shadows the hang
around Lord I fall
down
again I'm finding out just who I
Lord I fall
down
again I'm fighting out just who I
[Music]
am good by fear and good by shame good
by hopess and
pain now heard the
father call my
name I running good by Good by heaviness
and
lion has come the old is washed
away hello joy and hello truth
love long for
you waitting for this
moment oh
my Mercy H peace you have found me on my
knees I believe I'll never be the
[Applause]
same see your
face Everything Changes enough
Radiance of your
smile you got this way
up chasing away
those Shadows the
around I see your
face Everything Changes in the radiance
of your SP
got this
way she in the way
those Shadows that hang
around Lord I fall
down
[Music]
again I'm finding out just who I
am I fall
down
again I'm fighting out
just I
am hello joy and hello true hello love
i' long for
you waited for this
moment all my
[Music]
[Applause]
just let's allow ourselves to be someone
who's
[Music]
Fallen someone who messes up
let's be
[Music]
human and allow God to just meet us
right
[Music]
there will your grace
run
out if I let you
[Music]
down CU
all
I
know is how to
run I am a sin it's not one thing
another part of the words still in life
but you are a savior and you take
Brokenness Aside and make it
beautiful
beautiful will you call
me when
I
you right
[Music]
all
I
know is how to
[Music]
cry I
am it's not one thing it's
another CAU up in words
in you are Savior and you take
Brokenness inside and make it
beautiful
[Music]
beautiful you make it beautiful
you make it
[Music]
beautiful you make it
beautiful you make
[Music]
it I am
a it's not one thing it's
I'm CAU up in words tingled in
light but you are a savior and you take
Brokenness Aside and make
[Music]
beautiful
beautiful I am sinner it's not one thing
it's another
caugh up in words still in life oh yeah
you are Savior and you take
Brokenness and make it
beautiful
beautiful oh you make it
beautiful oh Lord
make
[Music]
beautiful
God we know the right that we should do
and still sometimes we choose a
different
path we know your goodness and your
mercy and your forgiveness and still
sometimes we turn away and we choose our
own convenience and our comfort Comfort
or our
selfishness we know sometime the work
that's in front of us to
do and instead sometimes I
[Music]
run God I pray that you would meet me in
my
Humanity in my
smallness in my Brokenness would you
meet us tonight show us the
places where we've turned and gone a
different
way and tonight would we hear your
whisper would you we hear you calling
our names calling us home to
ourselves to your
mercy to your
story to the good work that you're doing
here because we know God that that leads
to love that leads to beauty that leads
us to freedom and being whole and being
forgiven and that's the life that we
want to run
[Music]
after one that changes us for the
better one that brings us back to your
creation we trust you
we love you cuz you are a good
[Music]
god thank
you thank you for being
good oh we want to just wrap up this
time together by saying thanks would you
guys just say that out loud with me just
say thank you God tonight let's just say
it thank you
God he is good and we want to believe
that we want to live into that would you
guys turn to the people around you and
just um welcome them make them feel at
home and then Brett will get us started
on our mess we go into our next part
[Music]
come on
up Gary can you join us as he's trying
to simultaneously do sound and join here
y'all come come in the Middle come in
the Middle come on over don't know
hiding
so um sorry let me jump in
somewhere so um
yeah so tonight this is the elder
leadership team uh minus Raymond yes
yeah that's right that's right we're
just over here just so you could applaud
us that's it so you have to sit get down
um so yeah minus Raymond Lester is is on
vacation but um so tonight this is we
have kind of a significant thing uh
because Karen Miner has been on this
leadership team like the whole time from
day one to the table and before that she
was a part of another church plant that
a handful of us were a part of called
newcas and she was on that Elder
leadership team the whole three years it
went and before that at her that the
previous Church she was a part of she
was on the eldership leadership the
Elder leadership team for like I don't
know was a long time like 10 years or
something I mean so all day she's done
she's been on teams like this for a long
time and uh she feels it's time for her
not to be on a team like this and so I'm
going to let her share a little bit
about the process and and kind of how
she um has come to to this um kind of
decision and insight for herself so take
over uh yeah so listening to Brett talk
back my years in leadership like yeah
probably should have done this a while
ago it's time like the tldr of all of
this is it's time for me to rest to be
more about the being and less about the
doing trusting that God is is still God
and has got this whole community and
this church
in his and her and their very very
capable hands because that's who God is
so um yeah I about I don't know if I'm
honest probably over a year ago started
feeling some of the Rumblings of this uh
start to surface and uh it came out in
ways like leaving after after a Sunday
just completely exhausted and not
knowing why no good reason why um and
then a while later I had somebody put a
very very uh appropriate phrase to that
which is compassion fatigue and that's
where I've been for a while and I just
didn't realize it and um also realized
uh that I have been in crisis mode for
the better part of four years operating
at a high level of
hypervigilance
anxiety
worry
fear um just kind of trying to hold it
all together family kids uh this
community trying to Bear way too many
burdens that were not mine to carry and
um if you know anything about church
leadership Elder teams um um
pastoring by its nature it requires just
some carrying of stuff and all of us up
here Raymond included carry this
community at such a deep deep Heart
level um and that
requires some rest every once in a while
just to like up and that I think that's
healthy I think that's healthy every
July Brett takes the month off that's a
healthy rest Rhythm um that's not just
for anybody in leadership I think it's
for life in general is to take times of
rest and refreshment and that is what I
need to to do right now and so I've been
processing this with uh the Elder team
with Gary of course uh with Charles who
is our church uh coach who over there
and uh it's been really helpful to do
this in the context of community and not
just be off on myself you know by myself
myself just trying to figure out how to
do this but they've given me such
helpful handles and love and support and
really blessing and that's a gift it's a
gift for a a leadership team and a
pastor to say yes rest is good um versus
trying to hold on really tight um and so
that is what I'm entering into is a
season of rest and I'm not leaving the
church at all like this church is so
much a part of who I am it's not even
funny like I and I think that's some of
the work that I'll do too is some
identity work around I am not this
church like I there's I don't know
there's some stuff there I think that
God's going to just do some needed inner
work in my my soul on um but I'm not
leaving I'm just shifting a bit and so
I'll still be here but it might look a
little different and part of that for me
is taking that expectation off myself
I find that I do more of that than
anybody else I just think other people
put expectations on me so just know that
I'm figuring it out as I go I'm trusting
in the unfolding of it um and I've got
so much support and love around me um
and I don't know what the next season
looks like I'm hitting midlife I'm in
menopause I have kids leaving the nest
it's like all right it it just feels
like it's it's the time to take to take
a rest um and so uh yeah I don't know
what it's going to look like and I'm not
sure if I'll be back on the Elder team
at some point I'm holding that
open-handed maybe I'll serve in a
different capacity here at the table um
but that's te
te Tech
Team um but uh I just appreciate all of
you so much I appreciate this community
and um yeah I I can't wait to see what
God does with all of this I think
there's some good stuff for chapter 2 of
the table that's coming um and other
people that are going to step up into
leadership and um that's really really
exciting for me as well so thank you for
letting me
[Applause]
share so we wanted to um take some time
just to pray for Karen so ask Don and
Maggie to pray but kind of as a way of
joining in if you're comfortable you can
just kind of extend your hand out you
know just say like a sign of your own
prayer and um kind of support and love
for Karen as she makes this transition
so
joh let's
pray Jesus thank you so much for
Karen's thank you for her ability just
to be
here uh just I remember so many years
ago when I first walked through the
doors of a previous church and I was so
nervous after coming out after not
knowing where I could land not knowing
what was a safe space not knowing um
what the future could hold for me
spiritually and among so many people who
Tred this church Karen was one of those
people that just loved me and just one
of those people that saw exactly where I
was was um allowed me to just land
safely in this space and I know so many
the people here at this church feel the
same way about kieran's leadership and
her role here and I pray that this next
season for her is just exactly what she
needs just to
rest um just to um reconnect to be able
to focus not just on her needs but what
her family needs um and I just pray pray
that you will just um allow her just
to feel like this is a good use of her
time just her um at a time where she can
just feel whole in Christ's name I
pray yes God
we just start with
thanks and we're so deeply grateful um
for the years of investment and um
generous loving that Karen has done in
this community God we thank you for the
groundw work that she helped to lay God
we thank you for the dreams she held in
her heart and the many hours of um
behind the scenes work that she poured
into seeing this um come to
life and God I just I start with thank
you thank you so much for Karen um
beyond what she means to this community
that would we just thank you for who she
is and we bless
um this season of turning inward a
little bit and um being able to nourish
what's going on
inside God I pray that every seed she
has dropped up until this point would
continue to flourish and grow and Thrive
and bring forth New Life um and God I
also just pray that she would find
herself receiving from your I think of
the scriptures that call it a river of
delight and God I just pray for that for
Karen and um and we bless this changing
of Seasons God that is such a natural
part of life and as an elder team as a
church body God we just give it our yes
and amen
full-heartedly um we ask for the very
best for her and may it trickle down to
her family to her kids um to her
marriage and um and her friendships God
it's in your name that we pray
amen can you all give her a hand
[Applause]
know
[Music]
welcome Grace and
peace with you all andot
years now the church has um had its kind
of rhythms now I came from a wing of the
church kind of conservative Evangelical
Church that didn't do a lot of like um
Church calendar kind of stuff but uh
here at the table we've started to
ReDiscover that and um it's something
that's kind of it really has brought me
joy because coming from like you think
of sort of the secular world so to speak
um it's it tends to be kind of flat like
there sort of every day is the same and
then occasionally there's like a spike
like occasionally there's like a holiday
Fourth of July and it's like oh everyone
gets the day off and like fireworks and
it's sort of like and then just back um
we don't have many kind of like
Seasons rhythms and this is one thing I
really appreciate about the kind of
there's I think a certain wisdom in in
generations of the church realized like
hey there's you know there's different
seasons of life we just were talking
about one with Karen uh and there's kind
of different seasons that we go through
Even in our kind of Christian journey
and so in kind of the the church year
they realized like you know what if we
kind of followed the Life of Christ and
kind of did that across a year so you
have you know in Christmas of course
sort of his birth
and then you have that season of
epiphany which we just went through um
and then we come to now the season of
lint and this is where um we've kind of
been through a lot of his life and so
we're coming to the towards the the end
of things and so lint is the season it's
40 days not including Sundays um
actually you get some sometimes people
will take some space to like Fast
something or give something up for lint
uh but you're actually not supposed to
on Sunday cuz Sunday is like the
celebration day which is sometimes
people don't know that um so it's 40
days not including Sunday that lead up
to um kind of Good Friday and Easter and
so I would describe lint as like it's
kind of a slowburn movie which I like
some people are just too bored by
slowburn movies but I can do it where
because I like it where you can kind of
feel like oh gosh this is going
somewhere you know and um and that's
kind of what lint is like it's this kind
of slow it's a little bit contemplative
you know when I think of the the church
calendar there's kind of different
seasons and rhythms some are very
celebratory right of course Easter is
kind of very celebratory and even the
season after that um lint is kind of
that Slow Burn it's kind of very
contemplative it the themes are um kind
of our challenges our shortcomings our
struggles and uh and how it was that
ultimately Jesus was on the cross and
such right so it's kind of leading into
that and then suddenly at Holy Week
which kicks off on Palm Sunday uh the
week before kind of Good Friday and
Easter like it's like everything happens
just like a good slowburn movie
everything happens suddenly and like
it's just Palm Sunday it's like Hosanna
and then at the end it's like crucify
him and you got good Friday and then of
course Easter Sunday I mean it is just
like oh my gosh everything happens like
in the last week so um that's kind of
the Season we're entering is Lent so
we're in the I would say we're in kind
of the the slow bur portion uh right now
of of the movie so um with that in mind
we've got we're doing a little different
this year year we're going to uh do lint
with Julian of Norwich a Christian
Mystic I think this is my first time
ever to do like a series with the
writings specifically of a Christian um
Mystic and Julian was uh a Mystic she
lived from the year
1343 to sometime after 1416 we don't
know exactly when um in the English City
of Norwich you guessed it thus juli no
nor which and uh it's like 100 miles um
Northeast of of London and The Story
Goes at the age of 30 Julian fell
deathly ill like to the point she the
the priest came and gave her last
rights and she's there and suddenly she
she describes it as she was like an
immense pain and everything was kind of
hazy and but all of the sudden
everything got very clear the pain kind
of just drifted away and suddenly she
begin to have these Visions where like
Christ was speaking to her and these
have now the these writings they've been
kind of compiled into um a book called
Revelations of divine love and it has
resonated with just like generations of
the church there really if you've never
read it there's a a a version of it that
I found very readable um it's titled
Julian of Norwich the showings
discovering the face of the feminine and
Revelations of Divine love um it's by
mirabi star uh I would highly suggest
this version as Julian wrote in Middle
English which is like harder to read
than Old English like King James times
10 very difficult so you need a
translation you know and so this is like
a a super readable one so the title of
my message today is bruised bruised in
chapter 51 of Revelations the Divine
love the chapters are very short uh
Julian had has and and one of her
Visions was this moment where she has a
vision of a servant right remember she's
writing like 1343 so it's like this kind
of you know this Castle kind of setting
and there's a servant and then there is
a a Lord and she would say later that
the servant she felt kind of represented
humanity and the Lord of course
represented God and in the vision the
Ser the the lord gave this kind of word
or command to the servant and the
servant is like pumped eager to uh
follow through on this so she says she
sees the servant with this like smile on
their face and they Dart away running to
you know fulfill the the command or
whatever and
immediately the servant falls into a
deep
pit and there the servant experiences
what she calls the the seven pains um of
sin and um so kind of the series we're
going to be doing through through out
this lint is um basically we'll just be
going through those like seven although
I won't do them like linearly we we we
might jump around a little bit so um all
right so the first the first uh pain of
sin is she writes these words she says
in this state of Affliction right so the
servant's there in the pit the servant
endured seven Great pains the first was
the severe bruising he sustained when he
fell now I was struck by this language
of of bruising because like when I think
of sin I've tended to think of it very
psychologically you know like for
example if I like I don't know if I I
lie well then I'm like I'm sort of
hiding you know and I'm tormented but
but where am I tormented perhaps this is
because I'm an INR 5 and I'm like lost
in my head all the time maybe some of
you are very different you're like in
tune with the body this will come up
later in my message um this is a problem
for me but at least for me I like I am
I'm lost
in right and and I think and I wonder if
for some of us this is kind of how it is
where we're sort of you know we're a
little bit tortured in the
mind and and just to be clear like that
can be the worst right everyone knows
what it is to be sort of Lost in the
mind and struggling you know in that way
that can be its own kind of Hell uh in
fact I heard one therapist uh he said
after 20 years of Clinical Psychology I
can tell you one thing no one ever gets
away with anything they may appear
outwardly like they totally got away
with that you know nope they they are
torture you know it's like we all have
to kind of live um through this and hey
guys in the back I'm struggling with my
mic my poor glasses are just pushing my
microphone all around so I'm going to
switch to the handheld so
sorry but that's how it's got to go
tonight so thank
you
so now this is right this idea of the
mind right I'm kind of haunted in my
mind like that's that's different than
this this is like a this this is a
different kind of poetry it's a
different image you know I am
bruised I am bruised I love that like
that's it's
so taking me out of my mind and into
getting in touch with my body like can
anyone relate to this that and I know
this word by the way sin like lint does
a lot of sin talk that can be very
triggering and difficult for people um I
think often it comes back to our image
of God again um you know so let's let's
we're our Baseline here is God is love
God is compassion actually this is why
jul Julian norch has been known as
everyone's favorite IC because her image
of God Is So wildly loving I mean there
is like no ounce of anger and even in
this Vision the Lord sees you says she
looks at us in the pit with eyes of
compassion you know like there's no like
oh there you go again you're know like
no no so so okay yes it's it's it's sin
but not in a kind of condemning you know
but but in a like we can be honest you
know kind of way and and I I love this
this language because I can relate so
powerfully to it like boy has your sin
ever just left you like bruised so to
speak not not literally maybe you know
what I mean but but like bruised like
you ache you feel it in the
body and it's like you're you've been
punched pummeled abused aching again not
just in the mind it's it's bodily
and and sometimes this can be because of
like the big thing you know I don't know
whatever that might be for you often the
addiction plays out like this where it's
just like oh my gosh it just like leaves
you beat up you know so like okay
there's that sometimes though it can be
uh just like the small thing just over
and over and over and over and over and
you're just like oh it's almost like if
someone just hitting you in the shoulder
like just once like gently just once per
hour you know what I mean and by like by
like Hour 4 you're like ow by 10 she's
like oh my gosh please you know what I
mean but it's like they're not even
hitting hard but it just it just wears
you
down for me uh I felt bruised from
putting my children to bed at
night um parents parents
know oh my gosh specifically my boys I
don't mean to get overly gendered maybe
it's not all boys but at least my boys W
they were tough thank God they're
getting older now but for years it was
this like well there's I've learned this
about circadian rhythms they say with
your circadian rhythm you your energy
cycle it's lowest in the morning and
then it builds throughout like the day
kind of into lunch and you eat lunch and
then it drops and then it builds and
builds and builds all the way up right
before you go to bed your is your
highest it's your Peak and then it drops
off a cliff and that's we of course call
sleep now I didn't like know all that
until recently but I did know that
because of these two boys Maggie and I
we call it the witching
hour which I googled this week I was
like the we've called it this sounds
kind of dark what does that mean and I
go and it literally came from the idea
of the devil's hour and I was like
perfect it's the perfect freaking
description and I would like I would
literally I would have this little pep
talk to myself before this Rhythm this
daily Rhythm and I would be like Brett
Brett Brett BR okay okay last night
night before that night before that
night didn't go out but today it's a new
day buddy and you are you are you are
calm you are you Zen you you meditate
man you you're a meditator like so just
follow the breath I I'm just going to
follow the breath and everything is
going to be fine and I would go into the
bathroom and within like five minutes
they're throwing water in my face I feel
like emotionally abused I'm like stop it
and it's like I mean just and I'm
getting I can feel the my my my
spiritual director said br in touch with
your feelings in your body and so I
would start to do that and I could just
feel I could feel the anger like it's I
was like stop it you know I'm trying to
shampoo it's like they wanted the water
anywhere but in the tub and just start
flinging it and then finally somehow
mercifully we make it through and they
get out and just like be careful with
that towel please don't don't put the
towel on the ground it's just this is
the bathroom right it's just kind of gr
and they're just they're dragging their
towel across the toilet and I'm just
like please stop do you understand that
now that has to be washed now like give
me your towel you know what I mean I go
I come back they're running through the
house we live in community I know it's
not just our family we live with nieces
and nephews and they're running and
their aies like through or sometimes
less than that you know around the house
I'm like you cannot do that like I'm
just I'm just trying to H them and I'm
I'm getting them in and I'm I'm trying
to stay chill through I'm trying and I I
get them into their room and finally
it's bedtime you know what I mean like
it's time to go to bed freaking bed and
I get them down and it's not it's not
working they're having none of it and
I'm but I'm the law you know I mean and
but before I know it before I know
it cool Bret Zen
bre he is he is dead he is gone and I
just I slam him it's a little violent
not on them but I slam my hand on the
dresser and I
just I'm just like
quiet go to bed I have had it I have had
it with you
too I mean it's
just and then of course they look at me
like I'm the crazy person you know I
mean they're just
like
Pastor you liar you know I
mean
oh in that moment I mutter sometimes to
myself
quietly but I must admit I curse and I I
say parenting is bleeping impossible
that's what I whisper and in that
moment my circadian rhythm has plummeted
my boys of course are still going
strong but I just feel exhausted down to
my toes I can feel the adrenaline
pumping through my
body and the rage still in my fingers in
my
toes and I know it sounds so silly and
stupid but just imagine that times 2,500
days and I just feel freaking bruised
you know just like God bless I just
can't can't do this I cannot keep doing
this youve been
there anger rage resentment burning like
a
fire
man oh we're
bruised I have a friend uh Mike Nagel
he's a writer he's a good writer you
should get his book um his
books they are I would describe them
they're they're um
hilarious completely nihilistic and
Bleak uh I mean it's like he he grew up
Evangelical Christian has you know left
all that behind I don't think he claims
any faith now um but his me I call it
almost an anti- Memoir it's really he's
really hitting at the kind of
meaninglessness and the flatness of like
secular life and modern kind of Suburbia
he's poking in ways but it's it's but
it's wickedly like honest and and funny
um but he has this part he struggled um
with alcoholism part book one is some of
that is a theme through it and book two
is a theme of him kind of starting to
come out of that but book one called
duplex he described tries
um kind of being on this
bender and just to be clear my point in
mentioning this is not because I believe
you know if you drink alcohol it's a sin
I just I'll just say this we all know
there are lines that we
cross he he puts it this way he says oh
there's many types of hangovers I don't
mind telling you I am an expert on each
and every one of them this is the one
that feels like you're a tuning fork
vibrating at 256 Hertz a hangover that
lives mainly in the teeth and
bones I eat some leftover cauliflower
crusted margarita pizza and drink some
cold lime flavored toppo Chico and pull
my beanie down low onto my head none of
it helps of course but it still feels
nice to take care of myself like this
the only real cure I know for a hangover
is to start drinking again as soon as
possible but that's a dangerous remedy
I should know I once spent years years
curing and creating hangovers that way a
Mobius strip of pain and Pain Relief one
becoming the other back and forth until
it was hard to remember which one was
causing
which you been there in that pit I don't
just mean parenting or alcoholism I it
could be anything
sick
sore
spasmed
tormented
tortured
tender resentment like hot coals Envy
just eating you
alive the aftermath of lust shaking with
anxiety you steal
Elation you get caught you want to puke
you see sin it it's not just a torment
of the mind is
it it's
bodily and like a bruise it
lingers it lingers that's why I love
that image of a bruise even after long
after the Pain's gone it's like the
remnant The Echoes are still there in
the body
this is all captured um so eloquently in
the book of
Lamentations but you can hear the word
lament in Lament The Book of lament
Lamentations in um the Hebrew Bible and
the Book of Lamentations was um written
in the aftermath of 586 BC the
Babylonians came through and they just
conquered I mean they
devastated
Jerusalem and the whole Israelite ation
just it was maybe 20 30,000 people that
lived there and like half were either
dead or CED away to Babylon the rest
were left to pick up the remnants I mean
just imagine saxi or Wy or whatever Town
you're in and half the people overnight
gone like just I mean it was a disaster
and so it's from that experience that
the Prophet Jeremiah he's actually known
as the weeping prophet from his book of
Lamentations it's it's from that moment
that he um pinned these words in the
aftermath of that event this is
Lamentations
1:12 he says oh is it nothing to all you
who pass this way look and see is there
any
pain like my
pain is there any pain like my
pain echoing Lamentations 1 Julian
writes of the servant who fell into the
pit so focused on his suffering all he
could see was his what his
pain is there any pain like my
pain come and
see just feels like we're so often lost
in our pain we are bruised
I'm very
tempted at this point to um try and put
a very positive spin on this Perhaps
Perhaps too positive but of course it's
the season of lint and so I I'll resist
the temptation to do that you know
something like but least with Jesus
everything's going to be okay can I get
an amen everyone's like yeah you know
but it's like oh yeah that's true in
kind of a the big sense you know what I
mean at the end of all things all will
be well you know but what about today
what about this week what about right
now and that and that's where the
scriptures that's where Christ that's
where God are perfectly at ease with our
lament perfectly at ease saying you know
what it's okay just name it we are
bruised we just feel bruised we just
feel exhausted we just feel like we've
got nothing
left
and and perhaps what I do want to name
the one good thing one beautiful thing
is of course
that God does not add to our
bruising just like in Julian's Vision
the Lord didn't look at the servant and
be like oh come on failing again you're
like no no the the Lord looks with eyes
of
compassion and I want you to know that
God sees
you God sees
you and in fact the whole story of
Christ is the god who enters into the
pain and muck andm of the world and of
Our
Lives it's Christ who who did what Who
Bore our transgressions who was crushed
for our iniquities was was br
bruised just like we are
bruised and so tonight I think my just
have like it's almost just a little
prayer of oh Lord have
mercy Have Mercy I've come to love that
phrase sometimes that's like the only
prayer I got like I don't even know what
to say just Lord
Mercy Mercy not in the sense of God's
causing this and it's like Lord please
relent not not that it's more like the
world is just messed
up and so Lord for the sins we've done
or the sins just done unto
us feel
bruised so
Lord on all of my friends
tonight have mercy have mercy it seems
very um
fitting tonight it always feels fitting
but especially tonight and in this
season of
that we would come to the table of the
Lord and
so as we do that I I want you to to feel
like you can come to the one who sees
you with eyes of compassion the one who
knows what it is to be bruised and can
be with you in that pit
and perhaps over time work us
out so the way we're um going to come
forward to receive the the body the
blood of of Jesus tonight is um we'll
just go row by row here from the front
um and we'll work our way back so when
one Row's done the next one can come
forward we'll just form a line right
here um we practice what's called an
Open Table meaning if you're here
tonight and you'd like to participate
then you are free free to do that
regardless of theology or how far into
the pit you feel you are or something
like in fact the deeper you feel like
you are the better like the more we want
you to come forward um it's it's like
we're we're all there you know and um
finally you should know the red is wine
the white is grape juice and then you
can just partake however you'd like some
people like to come and kneel up here
you can return to your seat and partake
just however however you want to do it
so this is the
table not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith
and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to
follow and you just feel like you
failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet in here come to the table
[Music]
dear
God I've been trying awful hard to make
you proud of me
[Music]
it
seems the harder that I try oh the
harder it
becomes and I feel like giving
[Music]
up
most of the time
[Music]
dear
God I've been chasing their
approval and it's killing
me and I
know the more I try to prove oh the less
I have to
show and I'm stuck inside my head
most of the
[Music]
time but if I pray a little
harder if I follow all the
rules I wonder if I could ever be
[Music]
enough cuz I
try and I try
just to fall back down again and I ask
myself why do I try to chase the wind I
should lean into the mystery maybe hope
is found in a Melody so I want to
try
again oh I'm going to
try again
[Music]
dear
child I hope you know how much I love
you and I'm proud of
you please
believe thoughts I have for you will
never change your f Way
when you feel like giving
[Music]
up
I never
[Music]
did cuz I'm not squared of all your
questions with the questions in your
head just know that you have always been
enough
cuz you tried and tried and I saw you
wrestle with every and
everywh I was right there
listening so just lean to the mystery
and I'll meet you here in the
melody try just to
try again
oh child would you
try
again my child you can
love
[Music]
again thank you so much for joining us
this evening if you are new we would
love for you to fill out a card at the
table on your way out or just scan the
QR code on screens to fill out an online
visitor card that will allow us to
follow up with you answer questions you
might have say thank you for visiting if
you are in need of prayer a hug or just
general support come find me after the
service I would love to be there for you
however I
can here at the table we are committed
to creating an inclusive Christ centered
community that touches lives
and generosity is a key component of
that mission if you'd like to join us in
supporting this work financially you can
scan the QR code on the screens or at
the table over here to your
right or go to our website at the
tax.org
all right I'd like to send you out into
your week with this blessing please
stand if you're comfortable doing so you
can also help hold out your hands in a
posture to receive or just open your
heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day so as you go
into your week ahead with this yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with be
blessed have a good week please stick
around for the state the table meeting
ser starting shortly good
[Music]
night cuz I'm not scared of
imperfections or the questions in your
head just know that you have always been
enough cuz you tried and tried and I saw
you wrestle with every and
everywh I was right there
listening so just fall into the mystery
and I'll meet you here in the melody
just try to
try
[Music]
again oh child would you
try again
my child you can
love again